let's go to win from indiana win
go
hi uh can you hear me all right yeah i
can hear you fine
awesome so i have a question on
economics again
so i'm currently taking macroeconomics
and i've learned the effects of you know
spending and saving uh you mentioned a
lot about the marginal propensity to
consume yes and the multiplier effect
the idea that if you stimulate the poor
that leads to an increase in gdp and you
know economic growth and whatnot
but so so my question is
um
um so my question is
if you so the the theory is that
if you stimulate the
poor like demand right it it assumes
that prices are sticky right which is
our like prices don't change in the long
like in the short term i believe so do
you think in the real world prices are
really sticky
it depends uh on the industry and it
depends on the time horizon
so um i mean uh let i'll give you an
example so like
in the short term if you take something
like gas prices gas prices
respond to demand and they also as we're
seeing right now gas prices respond to
supply
but if you think about
for example the type of demand changes
that it takes to move gas prices we had
a pandemic where global air travel
reduced dramatically people driving
reduced dramatically and we saw gas
prices go down but for the most part if
we talk about
some
some demand side stimulus for
the lower middle class in the united
states
the amount by which their demand for gas
will increase is not really going to
have an impact on gas prices it's it's
too modest so that's an example of where
the additional money
to be able to you know maybe take a road
trip or whatever it will change the the
sort of uh
life of the person getting the money and
now having more money for gas
without really changing the price of gas
in a significant way it's sort of like
asymmetrical if that makes sense so so i
think the question is always of what
good or service and over what time
period is what we have to ask
i see so when we implement like specific
policies
um
we have to look which industry right and
then
um because some some demand side
stimulus may
be a negative be a disadvantage towards
some industry too right and with that
would that would you consider that like
good policy just the fact that it's
affecting
uh a different industry let's say the
service industry or like the industry
that is not really like a necessity so
well it's
we're it's getting a little bit muddled
what you're saying but i think what i
think the question you're sort of asking
is
if we think about demand side stimulus
as just being good because it gives
people more money to spend on stuff
don't we also need to consider
that increased demand as a result of
those people having more money can
increase prices and that might not be so
good
yeah yeah yeah that's it much phrase it
it
you really have to look at it more
specifically and you also have to
remember that in traditional economic
thinking a little bit of inflation is
considered good you don't want too much
inflation and you don't want deflation
and i've talked through the internal
logic of that so
just because some demand side stimulus
will cause a little bit of inflation
also doesn't mean it's bad i i apologize
because there's really not one answer to
this
right right right i agree but it sounds
like you generally understanding the
concept which is the most important
thing
yeah because i'm i'm in like this
i don't know like the middle phase kind
of like i don't know what to
unders like read or understand and just
wondering like i want to find like the
truth to this but then there's again
there's a lot of economic data backing
up the uh
the demand side uh stimulus i mean
demand side policy yeah i mean listen
you're asked you're you seem to be
bringing the right amount of uh
skepticism to the things that you're
learning which is fantastic
yeah yeah awesome
uh and one one really quick last
question
uh do you so
what are your thoughts on saving an
economic growth because there's also
some data on that like countries that
save more leads to they tend to have a
higher economic growth what were your
thoughts on that well so there's a
difference between the micro and the
macro level i mean we've talked before
about how
given the option of
giving a tax cut to a very rich person
or a poor person
the rich person is more likely to just
sock the money in a bank account because
they don't really need that money to
live whereas the poor person is more
likely to spend it and the spending has
a higher multiplier than the saving it
in a bank account so that's at that like
the individual level
at the same time
saving
at the macro economic level meaning how
much is society saving in total
is a sign of economic health because it
means you don't have a society with as
many people on the brink of
not being able to afford basic expenses
so when we think about who do we want to
target for tax refunds or tax credits we
would have one answer to that and we
might say well just putting the money in
a bank account's not so good as in terms
of a multiplier at the macro economic
level a higher savings rate within
reason is a sign of economic health so
the answer is different depending on
whether you're talking about macro or
micro
okay because but if we're targeting if
we want like for the benefit of society
um you know obviously gdp is not
everything right no but like for the
benefit of society
then probably
tax cuts for the for the wealthy isn't
really the best option currently that's
what the data shows yeah
okay okay got it all right thank you so
much david all right thanks well when
with some of the meatiest economics
questions we've had in a while i
absolutely love it all right everybody
we're going to go to a break we will
take calls again soon